your first conception the most famous
conception that you had originally uh
publicly at least uh was the chimp
Paradox if if people aren't familiar
with the chimp model how do you
introduce them to that
I'll try and keep this thing to put I'm
glad that 30 years now so uh yeah I'm
getting old very old uh and I as a young
doctor
um I suddenly started realizing I was
talking to two individuals in therapies
where and again I'm making this very
black and white uh one of the two
individuals I talked to was very
rational and Common Sense and would
engage me the other was highly emotional
and usually very irrational and
distorted in the weather perceiving
things themselves the world of the
people but I could get the one that was
irrational to become rational by talking
and going through things so that
intrigued me that I had two people in
the room and some people they were close
some people were miles apart so then
turn into neuroscience and looking at
the brain there are circuit trees in the
brain that are just automatic that
outside of our control
and as a psychiatrist obviously as a
doctor I'm learning also the therapeutic
background we have as a base so go right
back to Freud and you think yeah he was
a genius of his time and he recognized
the drives and the instincts but what
can we see now at the 1990s was the
functional Mi scanners came in and now
we see actually these parts of the brain
they're not just drives and instincts
there's an entire system that thinks and
interprets and makes these
interpretations without permission
and makes decisions without permission
often based on the drives and instincts
so you have this amazing machine that's
trying to run our lives at the same time
as we're trying to impose our values and
the way we want to run it so I was
intrigued with this so you mentioned
wait at the beginning and I often use
that as the best example how many people
get up in the morning saying today I'm
going to eat healthy the right amount
and at the end of the day they say again
it hasn't happened you know and they
were they were saying why is it that
this is happening because it's crazy and
then they attributed to willpower
whereas the newer science teaches
something different it shows that
there's an entire system based on
Survival which thinks and decides and
it's also impulsive and it looks for
instant gratification so when you're
offered something you like say Donuts or
peanuts and you think I've eaten enough
this system says no no we've got a
little bit more because it doesn't see
what's coming
so I was intrigued so I spoke to omitted
Specialists the great apes I'm I'm very
much an animal lover so as part of the
great tips the humans are one of the
five
um what they said to me simplifying it
was the looking at the gorilla the
orangutan and the bonobo they think
their brains operate differently to us
but the chimpanzee doesn't it's the same
it's the same thinking interpreting
emotionally based system so I started
looking and I started recognizing
watching chimpanzee behave in human
there was such similarities however when
we turned to rationality and logic we
change that behavior and we become very
different so what I discovered of sort
of light bulb for me I'm sure others
have discovered it what what I really
for me discovered was you've got this
inner chimp system that we've inherited
alongside you as a human and we've all
got it and depending how strong it is or
how we learn to manage it is how often
it will present
and that became more and more prominent
in when I was working with individuals
to said you didn't think that that is
the chimp system
now that got published uh in 2018
to show the chimpanzee and the human
have the same kind of thinking systems
which separates us from the rest of the
Apes
um but by then I didn't want to wait
that long because I think it was
blatantly obvious I know we have to give
evidence so I started using it on my
medical students I'm at Sheffield
medical school and at that point as
undergraduate Dean I was working a lot
with youngsters between 18 and 23. so I
started explaining you do have this
chimp system
um they loved it they really got this
they said I can recognize when I'm in
chimp mode when I'm in human mode and
they started send teachers there so it
became part of what I did with them and
we'd talk about what are the drives that
are strong in your gym because the chimp
brand is unique to the person again so
it became an entertaining way of
starting to understand what you're
sharing your brain with this incredible
system which thinks and acts for you
with a major backup system
so when I started doing this simplified
Neuroscience the students were not keen
on the newer sides because it was too
complex they kept saying make it so it's
practical which I wanted to do so they
all started giving their chips a name uh
and this went on for a good 10 years
before
I effectively got catapulted into the
Limelight with sport uh which was a side
track
um and then it became public and it just
went a bit viral and you know I started
meeting people saying they asked me the
chimp man I'm proud to say I'm the chip
man but I think the key for me was I saw
transformation of people who started
recognizing the difference between
themselves and the Machine so that's why
I called it the chimp Paradox and I
wrote the chimp Paradox uh probably over
about four years trying to refine it I
didn't want to get it wrong so I put out
when I thought as close I can get it to
explain this is your brain and how it
works there were I kept being pestered
to go into more detail and that's why it
took me 10 years to actually think okay
do it again so I rewrought effectively
and called it a path through the jungle
so a path of the Jungle is more with
it's got the evidence base the research
behind it um I know in America the gym
Paradise didn't take off and I know I
was criticized because there was no
evidence so I thought they're right to
say that so I've now given 400
references
and I'm pleased to say it was assessed
by Cambridge Neuroscience department and
they said it's spot on so there is a
right upon Kevin's University's website
for those who are academically
interested to say that they were saying
that yeah this is an amazing model and
it's very detailed uh to link it to
Neuroscience why would it have been
useful in our past to have this very
reactive
uh set up inside of our minds
it's still useful now
um when we look at I'll talk in terms of
the model when you're using the human
circuits the transmitter systems and the
speed at which they conduct are
relatively slow
so when we think rationally we think
steadily
whereas if something dramatic happened
where our life is at risk we need to
think quickly and act impulsively almost
instinctually
so the chimp system can do that for us
so in a serious emergency it will know
what to do so it generally uses fight
flight freeze because that's what the
amygdala hands to it as part of that
system that's running so if you were say
with someone who suddenly drew a knife
instinctively you'd know what to do
you know whereas if you had to think
rationally the little split seconds
could cost you dear so but you can
imagine this in many circumstances where
there's an apparent danger we act very
instinctively and our machine takes over
and it's pretty accurate
so it's not that it's a bad system at
all and people gave this my inner chimp
bit and I'm in one of the elite athletes
I once said how do I kill my chimp and
I'm thinking you've really not got this
because my chimp system is my best
friend
because as long as I understand what
he's trying to tell me what is the ways
communicating then I can use that and
work as a team and the there's evidence
strong research evidence on this that
when we use a logical basis to our
thinking and an emotional instinctive
intuitive basis it works best on their
own it don't work as well so I keep
saying the chimp's the best friend
you've got hence the paradox
uh you know but you can make it your
worst enemy if you're going to start
saying you know I hate myself I hate the
fact I ate too much I hate the fact that
I lose my temper that's not really very
helpful at all the approach is wrong you
need to for my opinion you need to be
saying if I'm getting annoyed what is
this part of my brain trying to tell me
you know why is why is this evoking this
emotion I mean what can I do to stop
this and that's what I started doing
with patients back in the 1990s I
started applying it in my clinical
practice uh and I'm pleased to say I got
some amazing results
um I don't attribute that to me I don't
I think the person is the one who gets
the results they get insight and they
they worked with me all I can do is help
them and catalyze what their
understanding is but the people who
grasp and understood themselves and the
way the machine was working and got the
chimp and what I call a computer on
board they started saying it's
life-changing it's really changed me
because what they're doing is saying I'm
now in charge of the machine
and they're making it run and using it
when it kicks a bit to say what is it
you're doing and they say this is great
and that's what I tried to do I said
it's a different approach I know it's a
bit a bit out of the box but I wanted it
based on Neuroscience because that's my
academic background as a as a professor
in in Psychiatry I'm Neuroscience based
it seems to me that there's broadly two
buckets of people that you've worked
with you've sort of worked with the
human mind at its best and the human
mind at its worst as well
what is different
or are there many fundamentals that are
the same for trying to get Chris Hoy to
be in Flow State during the Olympics as
they are trying to deal with somebody
who is highly dysfunctional uh and who
doesn't really like the inside of the
texture of their own mind do you have
different approaches when it comes to
that or is it broadly the same physics
I said beginning which I know people can
get frustrated with me because I do a
lot of these like magazines or they tell
you might say give us five tips for our
viewers or and I can't do that so I
often warn people don't ask me because I
I can't do that because it does boil
down to uniqueness so I can only talk
about people I've worked with who've
gone public and say please you know use
me if you want to so we're going to use
I'll use Chris Hoy I mean he's I've
known Chris 20 years now and it was an
absolute pleasure and privilege to work
with me he's a real gentleman so when I
met him he was in a great place he's
never had any emotional you know
disturbances in life of any catastrophic
kind so he's a very even balanced very
rational man but what Chris said is I
believe uh he's insightful that if I
work with you you can explain how my
mind works and I'll be able to get focus
on the track for the event I want to do
so why did his work with him and said
tell me what your thinking is now what
is it you're trying to do with this
event what would help what wouldn't and
we worked a pattern out how he we plan a
mental program for his event so clear
that it's purely on what Chris did with
me but what I found is his chimp is a
gentleman too so the chimpin Chris is so
close to Chris that you don't get these
outbursts you just don't get them but
Chris would always tell me I know the
difference so even when he said when I
go emotionally based there's a risk so
we did a lot of good fun work uh
incredibly good I call them students I'm
a mentor
um great so he's one extreme of a
balanced individual who said how do I
optimize or get better up while I do
whereas probably the most popular person
I work with Ronnie O'Sullivan who came
to me very dysfunctional and has a
really large chimp and Ronnie says tell
the world everything I'm not going to do
that all I can say is a fantastic guy
that I really like and get on with we've
worked together now over 10 years and
his chips very active Roni himself is
subjected to this so he's trying to
learn how to manage it so Irani as a
human being is very very different to
his chimp so I can see even in
interviews when Ronnie's answering oh
and his chimps answering
um and so with him it's more
perfecting the skill but I can say that
I've worked in 10 years and it's a
privilege and he's great fun
um that over those 10 years as he
approaches the world championships in
snooker which is won multiple times
um each year he's improved and and
that's a really key point for working
with people that all of us can get the
skill some others are going to pick it
up very quickly so I've worked with
people who've transformed themselves
within weeks months they have light bulb
moments but they put a lot of time and
effort in whereas other people it's
really tough to get the skill you know
it's no different to say learning to
sing we can all sing but some are
brilliant to start with and get even
better and some of us struggle uh but we
can still improve of it and emotional
skills to me are exactly the same you
have a starting point I don't know what
potential people have until I work with
them so I get someone who can start a
square one in a really bad place and end
up fantastic in a great place I actually
saw someone this morning and I've worked
with on and off over 10 years and she's
in an amazing place now but didn't start
there but really worked on it and
increased the skill to it's great to say
that how should we best understand our
emotions
okay because
I know what you're asking is is great uh
however I just say you'll get frustrated
with me however it's like saying teach
me Italian if I can't speak it and teach
me in the next 10 minutes you think
where do we start you're very basic
stuff so I think the answer for me this
is only me to best understand this start
going steadily it's not a promotion but
it's why I wrote a path to the Jungle
because I think it takes you through 27
units so it says start and build up so
you learn things gradually you practice
them so I give exercises so again one of
the early starting points is
understanding the difference between you
and your your brain working
if you can see the difference and you
recognize I know who I am now that in
itself can lift self-esteem phenomenally
because you stop muddling yourself up
with a machine that's overpowering you
so that concept is not as easy as it
sounds to grasp you can get it logically
but when you the day you actually get it
conceptually you can't go back you
suddenly realize I've been hijacked or
I'm being sweared by a machine not me
and I'm very different to that machine
so that's the starting point then you go
on I would then go on to emotions and
say can we start seeing them differently
can we see them as messages
that are coming from the chimpa computer
system to give you an alert or a
question
you know so anger for example not every
time but anger can be that you've not
processed something from the past you
need to go back and process it it's
still underpinning the way you're
approaching the world of people however
it may be nothing to do with the past it
could be current belief systems that I
can't deal with life if it doesn't go
away I think it is and that can create
anger the next one can be unrealistic
expectations of other people or yourself
and that can create anger
uh it can even be a feeling of rejection
so you're going into relationships or
meeting anybody every day with the
defense position and that will lead to a
potential angle which is more of a
defense mechanism so you can see anger's
just an emotion for me the the emotions
not too important the fact you're
getting a message is what's important so
anger despondency frustration that's
what your chimp brain is choosing to use
and some of them use the same emotion to
alert you and it's non-appropriate
emotion so I would start saying let's
look at emotions differently and let's
understand the differences between them
and that's why I spend two units I
believe in the path through the jungle
to try and say look really at the very
early stages let's understand what's
happening here before we go on to start
perfecting things like values and
communication let's understand what our
emotions are you mentioned about how
self-esteem can become degraded
if people are unable to
um work through this conflict that's
that's going on inside of them why is
that or how do you how do you
conceptualize just self-esteem as a
topic and do you see this uh this
tension as one of the most common or one
of the common reasons why people's
self-esteem can become a little bit
eroded
I think for me that the main reason
people have low self-esteem I'll give
the example you give up eating uh we
could use it for angle could use it
anything is if the person says I'm going
to set off today and I know my values
all right I'm going to treat people with
respect I'm going to remain calm and
collect because that's who I am then
they're defining themselves and they're
saying that's me setting off
if they now go out and overeat what
they're now saying is not I'm a greedy
person or I'm a weak will first that's
now so derogatory and causing
self-esteem to drop and that's not
scientifically accurate that's not
accurate what is accurate is to say I've
set off with the intention of doing the
following and now this system has now
impulsively started eating now before we
get people's who are listening saying us
good excuse It's non-excusable you're
still a hundred percent responsible you
can't just go that I'm a chimpy too much
I don't accept that all right I say oh
no no you have to manage the chimp so
you can't get angry with someone and
blame the chimp it's not a excuse Bloom
that's what I say is your job is to say
apologize and then say okay this is the
difference in esteem I know who I am
what I can't do is manage the machine
well and all of us struggle with that
what I need to do is learn to manage the
machine up skill on it and that could
take me some time that means you know
who you are still and you're not
muddling yourself up with a machine and
starting to come up with silly
interpretations such as I'm an angry
person there isn't an angry person
unless you really believe that's who I
want to be which is nonsensical so I do
rebuke people I'll ask when I'm working
with they come in and say I got really
angry this week and I said no you didn't
unless you're telling me that's what you
want to be and then they'll say no no I
don't want to be angry and I say in
other words You've Got Hijacked so let's
look at Why You Got Hijacked and let's
give you the skill to manage the hijack
and calm the chimp down
so it is subtle but it's I don't know if
you can grasp what I'm saying I'd have
made it clear absolutely yeah yeah it's
what's what's interesting is this
might be the wrong word almost like a
depersonalization of you who you are at
your core
and things that you do
the things that you do okay
yeah the word is dissociation uh you're
dissociating you're saying to yourself
this is me and now I've got this chimp
machine uh along with a computer that
this machine in my head so I'm now going
to go forward but if something happens
and it provokes that and it overtakes me
I'll now present to the world my chimp
all right present a mixture of me in the
chimp and the ideal for me is to always
present yourself to the world but get
your chimp and computer as well because
they're not bad things you know our
chips could bring color to our life so
if we have a chip that's got a sense of
humor which they do have because our
sense of humor is in the chimp system
not in the human
all right so the chimp will bring us
mirth and humor that's why the chimp
believes something we say that's why
punch lines work and then it realizes
that's ridiculous and it causes to laugh
so there are actually three different
circuits they're being all based in the
chimp system so if we didn't have that
we probably would be pretty boring yeah
because it wouldn't let we wouldn't
laugh so you're saying let's get on
board but you're the person who says
these are my values these are my beliefs
uh this is how I want to behave in life
and that you set out so I work a lot on
that with people and say now we know who
you are don't worry if you get hijacked
and you presents something different to
the world just recognize we've got work
to do and we're going to learn that
skill and it it will happen
you'll always get chimp hijacks tell me
if I Rumble too much because I get asked
a lot about do you have a chimp and I my
chin wrote the books you know it decided
to collude with me because I think was
tired of telling me uh but as a young
man yeah I experienced a lot of anxiety
a lot of frustration a lot and I I
couldn't work this out but as a psyche
I'm thinking well you need to work it
out you're the person who's going to be
helping people you can't be that it's
hypocritical so I can't help myself but
then I realized that yeah like everyone
else I have a chimp most of the time on
how to manage it and it's on board and
he's my best friend uh so for me one of
the things I do is be sarcastic with it
I don't know why my channel finds that
funny so if something upsets my chimp
system and I experience frustration or
whatever I do say to the gym can we just
answer the question do you want me to be
upset for an hour a week the rest of our
lives and for some reason my chimp gives
away immediate laughs and things okay
it's got get a life get this
and we're okay but I've worked that out
that that works for me 99 of the time
there will be a time when my chimp
hijacks me and then I have to say okay I
Got Hijacked because I'm no different to
anybody else
so but I need to learn again which
everyone does what are my trigger points
so trigger points for me where I know
I'm vulnerable to losing this management
at the gym would be bullying
seeing someone intimidated my chimp
comes straight in and so I have to be
careful in situations where I say okay
I've got it let me do the daily if you
don't speak it seems like a real art
form to be able to integrate this
the the chimp with the human mediated
you know in the middle and that chimp
human computer relationship
seems like a very delicate dance because
as you say if it was just
um raw rationality and pure cerebral
horsepower and cognition all day it
would probably remove an awful lot of
the color and a lot of the joy as well
from the things that we do and it is I
think a lot about about finding that
balance I've heard you talk about ghost
emotions what are those yeah
yeah sometimes we learn learn a behavior
and it doesn't belong in real time so a
simple example is we can get a bad
experience of say public speaking now
that would evoke most people's chips to
start getting anxious so the computer
will always come to the rescue if you
look at what beliefs and memories you've
got so we can tamper with a computer we
can't do much with the chimp it's it's
the nature of the animal we have to
manage it the computer we can tamper
with but let's have a bad experience
doing public speaking it's very likely
I've learned to become anxious so when I
stop myself and why are you doing this
it's a learned behavior it's a ghost
emotion it doesn't belong there and it's
not actually what I want to experience
or indeed should be experiencing so
ghost emotions are something that hang
on inappropriately they can be because
we haven't processed but it can just be
a behavior where you think let's change
that behavior so I find a lot of people
carry emotions and it's just something
they've learned to do so you can
desensitize them to situations and and
ignore the ghost
there's a difference the reason I
brought that in is and again this is the
devil in the detail some emotions are
scars they're not ghosts and it's very
important to get the difference between
them so when I work with people if
you've got a scar say you went through a
really bad breakup
um most people don't come out on scarred
um so you've got some scarring from the
relationship breaking or whatever it is
um and you can't process it so I keep
saying to people sometimes I always try
and process it and you can do it maybe
the later stage but a bit more process
it's a scar and there's a different way
of dealing with that so we have to have
we we deal with that Not By ignoring it
by actually managing it so it can be to
talk it through again because that helps
us even though we know it won't resolve
it it will actually take pressure off so
some scars obviously the world I'm in we
mentioned sport but I work a lot with
your public uh and generally speaking
the people I meet are not in a good
place so I do work with a small number
of parents who've lost their children
and that must be excruciating and it is
for them and my Approach I know other
people might have a different approach
um is to say to them it is an emotional
scar it's not something you're going to
get rid of it's not something you'll
ever even come to terms with I think
it's something you've got to manage you
know and and accept that there will be
some terrible days ahead but there'll be
some good days but it's that's a scar
for me so I don't try and remove it
because I don't think you can yeah it's
very um it's it's the more detailed that
you apply to looking at the inside of
your own mind the more that you realize
there are very subtle nuances between
different things whether that be the
ghosts or the scars what do you mean
when you talk about stabilizers of the
Mind
yeah sometimes the mind can become
emotionally up and down so I'll try and
give a simple example to bring the point
home let's say that let's say I I do a
lot of public speaking and let's say
that I go to an audience and I'm trying
to get across everything I do and it
doesn't come over and I think I'm not
getting there today I'm fumbling with
everything I do
um I might leave that hole in my chimps
unstable because it's saying you know
you didn't do a great job there and
maybe I I made a joke that was near the
knuckle and it was meant inside our
cousin to make them laugh and it didn't
come up and I think oh gee I probably
offended someone so my children would
beat me up for this or try so I
stabilize My Mind by saying to the gym
hang on you did your best you live by
your values it's not that you didn't try
you know you did everything you could
you got it wrong all you did you weren't
on form today which no one can be every
day so get a life and then I will bring
perspective a week from now and I'll be
is even bothered the only person I'll
remember is you you know so perspective
is a stabilizer of the mind and so a lot
of people for me it's a massive one so
again you hear people commonly saying
will this matter in an hour in a week
and a year and for a lot of situations
it really most situations doesn't matter
so that's an example of one stabilizer
of the Mind
I love broadening time Horizons like
that and it's something that I found
myself really poor at doing uh in my
past that the decision that I was making
right now was going to be the decision
that I would have to live with for the
rest of my life that this
purchase of a car or this move to a new
city or this change of a house or this
makeup or breakup of a relationship or
whatever it would be it's like when you
realize that most things are time bound
and most things are subject to change in
future it helps to
release a little bit of the pressure and
the same thing can occur for public
speaking or a bad podcast I do a bad
podcast I'm like well I've got two more
to do this week and in a year's time
there's going to be 150 more released so
you can't have a good podcast every
single time that you do it and it helps
to release and relinquish some of that
Obsession I think that we have and the
pressure that we apply to ourselves
and I think you're demonstrating when I
start working with people to say let's
look at what we mean by this chimp
system what does it work with what can't
it do one of the things it can't do when
our blood supply goes into the chimp
system which is the orbited frontal
cortex just above your eyes when that
lights up it cannot gain perspective it
struggles with perspective so and it
can't bring reality to a situation
because it's very emotionally based the
way we see things so if you have your
bad podcast it struggles with this it
starts catastrophizing
um and you it wants to go over and over
and over it doesn't actually want a
solution
it just wants to get rid of the problem
and there's a subtle difference whereas
if we can train your brain to move to
human mode this is what I'm doing by my
computer coming to the rescue saying as
a human being I've got rationality and
saying you know and I've got values so
you bring in which the human system does
which is the top he had we see that
light up you now bring perspective in
so but the complexity of the brain is
that the human can't take the Chimp on
if there's a fight between these two the
chimp will always win because it has
transmitters that can actually
annihilate the human from functioning so
we get hijacked literal emotional
hijacks where people act out and they
can't do it
um and people say well that means I'm
doomed because my Gym's always going to
win but this is the subtlety because
I've explained in the books that uh the
way the chimp works it knocks the human
out but it must necessity though says
turn to the computer and scan which we
see it literally scanning the computer
and getting advice uh beliefs
experiences intuition it gets masses of
information within a split second which
then advises the Chim which it has to
follow what to do so if we program our
computers well that's the secret of
managing the mind so we program them so
that when the chimp knocks us out our
computer takes over and manages the gym
so there is a way around this it's not
Doom and Gloom but if you don't program
the computer and keep it running
then the chimp will definitely take
control
a couple of words that you've been using
a lot throughout this conversation that
I want to dig into values beliefs
drives what how do those fit together
how do we know what our true drives are
Etc
drives are innate compelling
um emotions feelings we get they're
biologically driven so there's a drive
to eight
and everybody has that drive so it's
exceptional not to have an eating drive
all right most people it's extremely
strong because it's a survival drive
it's Common Sense there's a there are
lots of drives there's a derived for
security
so and it's where you turn to fulfill
that drive so we talked to teenagers
who'll turn to their peer group for
security and we've explained that's got
uh traumatic results at times but if we
turn for security to our environment
that will help the chimp but not
necessarily the human our humans turn to
security by looking within ourselves and
our resources and what we think we can
manage in life so a human for security
doesn't go on the environment it may
help but it won't help in overall the
chimp will look on the environment but
get in the right environment but that
doesn't help with the mind so you can
often get a great environment what The
Chimps do the humans still agitated
saying I don't feel so other drives uh
the sex drive is very powerful and
obviously that leads to a lot of
difficulties with a lot of people
because they can't manage it and the
chimp can take over see if there's
nothing in the computer we're getting to
difficulty so drives are compelling
things that get us out of our seats with
doubt was having to do anything they
just make us move first is a drive the
drive for first there's lots of them the
drive to be with the people if you move
on to beliefs these are now what your
experiences are or what you've been
taught
so a belief for example again I'm taking
extremes
um let's say I believe that all people
are good and they're nice I'm leaving
myself very vulnerable to those that I
know will take advantage of me so I'll
be taken in I'm naive if I have that
extreme belief if I have the extreme
beliefs that all people are not to be
trusted that can have repercussions of
me feeling very isolated and not
trusting someone so I don't get any
depths of friendships or interpersonal
relationships so you have to look and
say what are your beliefs so if you have
a belief which I push a lot uh that the
one in five release and that's based
more on reality under the research
that's given that about one in five
people love you regardless all right
they're pretty deluded really because
even when you're not in the right
they'll still believe you all right one
in five people criticize you regardless
unfortunately they're often the most
vocal so unfortunately the social media
these are the main bulk of people coming
out and that's really sad that we have
one in five people who are quite
acrostic and three out of five are
reasonable decent people are where
you're up on what you do so they're like
if you really Anonymous but they
probably won't if you're not so if you
have that belief that one in five people
you need to be wary of because and one
in five people don't get flattered and
misled but three out of five learn who
the balance ones are if you want
soundboarding so if you're going with
that belief which I believe is the
correct one but that's my bias
then it means I'm constantly assessing
hang on is this someone I trust or is
this someone who's gonna just flatten me
and or is this someone who's balanced
and will challenge me appropriately and
then make me stop and think hey I'm on
them I have a point
so beliefs are something that guide you
but they're quite strong
because obviously these are what I call
the Gremlins and the autopilots that if
these but you try to do something in a
belief stops you then that can be a
positive influence or a negative
so even sensible beliefs like don't
skate on an icy pond
you know especially if it's thawing you
know that's common sense so you have
that belief because you are distorted or
you've experienced it
so that's beliefs beliefs you have
millions of beliefs some of them are
very strong and some of them are not
that influential but we form them
generically and we form them
specifically for circumstances
um values are really important to me
the reason I push value is when I
started doing this work 30 years ago and
creating this model of the Mind as I was
going to use for my patients
um and again there will be people who
disagree with me I'm only given you what
I believe and what's experienced over
the last 30 years the only thing that
gave peace of mind which is different to
happiness so peace of mind is knowing
what your values are and knowing at the
end of the day you've lived by your
values
so I worked on my values and I found no
matter what happens around me whether I
get criticized misunderstood
misrepresented these things will disturb
most of us at the end of the day I can
look in the mirror and think have I
lived by my values and if so I'm at PACE
with myself it doesn't matter it's
uncomfortable but I can live with it
because I'm I respect myself so when I
looked at this and did it with
experience with patience everyone said
once you know your values you're almost
immune you start realizing that's what's
going to stabilize me and give peace of
mind so it's very important to know how
to find values and what they are and not
model them up with things like what's
valuable to me that's not about you so I
was trying to say once you've got your
values then you can measure which I ask
people to do demonstrate your values in
action every day because that will bring
you a peace of mind thinking I did the
right thing
in your experience where do most people
go wrong
when it comes to working out their
values sitting down with a piece of
paper or doing some exercise online or
whatever what are the do's and the
don'ts when it comes to defining values
for most people very nice
confusing it because if you go online
and say what's a value you're going to
get a lot different definitions
so I had to say well what am I talking
about so the people I work with I try
and agree this is the definition of a
value and then at least we're on the
same page so I'm going to go with what
I've created as a definition but a lot
of other people have got a certain
definition I agree with them
so a value is immoral belief that you
hold something you think is what should
happen a decent person which is going to
be me I'm going to live by this decent
value or this belief which is going to
be acted out with a behavior
so for example like they can be subtle
let's say which many people do I want to
respect everyone because if I normally
disrespect someone I feel bad I lose my
peace of mind if I unwittingly
disrespect someone and then realize it
or get told that will unsettle me so I
need to know how do I measure respecting
someone so for me I would put down
number one is
I listen to someone I don't have to
agree with them but I give them an
audience I don't attack them I listen
and what their views are I listen to
their views and I I believe personally
for me that's showing respect
so if I wanted to say let's just check
on respecting people I'm gonna have a
week where I actually say how many times
did you dive in without listening well
how many times did you stop especially
in an emotional discussion how many
times do you stop and say I want to
actively listen to what they're saying
understand it I don't have to agree or
understand it and respect that value or
that belief so that's an example uh what
people do is they muddle things up they
say things like uh my car
you know that's not a value because
there's no Behavior it's what you're
saying is valuable to me I really get a
lot of pleasure and enjoy it out of my
car but that's not going to be bringing
you peace of mind
all right it may bring you happiness
so and I like to work on happiness
separately to peace of mind
a lot of the exercises that I've seen
online looking at things like core
values do work you come up with answers
with things like uh curiosity Adventure
self-development self-care
it seems like a key part of your
definition is that it is there is an
action there is something which is it's
going to influence your behavior and how
you show up in the world
um yeah certain things like curiosity uh
become very nebulous and difficult to
Define
uh you know they're they're like um
intrinsic parts of your personality or
the bits of you that you enjoy or
respect but when it comes to creating
like enacting that it feels like there's
a little bit more of a difficulty going
on there is there anything to say about
that about uh some of them yeah
yeah I mean I get your point I think for
me uh curiosity comes under what I would
Loosely call is the drive for
stimulation
um so some people the stimulation will
be just gone on a computer game but the
brain is satisfied with that whereas for
many people it wants difference it wants
new experiences it wants to see what
would happen if so we know that some
people are more prone to saying let's
test things out let's and some people
are wanting to achieve something so I
always put under this uh heading of
stimulation
and again most of us have got something
we want as a stimulus but it canning be
as straightforward as a social group it
doesn't have to be you know I'm going to
learn a new language or I'm going to get
to a new level on a computer game and so
I try and explore that with people to
say what are you doing to give stimulus
to both you're human and your chimp what
is it they both want and what's going to
satisfy that and again I think there's
different drives for the human and chimp
so I work out because some people are
much more terrible and say I'd like to
have a discussion group like you know
reading a certain book and going in the
club and discussing it with others
that's a nightmare uh the stimulation
could be just being part of a group that
supports a football team
but you're looking to see some people
get stuck and they don't have any
and then they'll say things like I feel
dissatisfied and it's hard when you
don't know which way to turn
um I do um I love animals I've got a lot
of animals around me I've removed some
from the room in case I make noises
while we do this uh so I rescued some
animals and
um I know some people discover that so
I've had people I've worked with and
they've said once you get an animal not
for everyone uh suddenly you've got this
responsibility this interaction this you
see the animals World differently and
it's they use that as displacing care
onto the animal and they get great
satisfactions that's one example so I
would explode with people what you're
calling curiosity I'd say stimulation
the drive to get stimulation and
experience
yeah that's very interesting uh I think
I probably need to revisit uh my what
I've deemed core values perhaps
erroneously uh it was maybe three or
four years ago when I put mine together
and in there were a lot of things I
actually can see as stimulation two of
them were curiosity and adventure and
they're things that I like to do but I'm
trying to run them through a more
fine filter which is okay how does this
inform the way that I behave in the
world and I don't know if they
necessarily give me
Guidance with regards to that so I think
okay
let's do some therapy hit me hit me
there's only there's only a million
people watching so it's fine cool that's
fine it's not really therapy it's just
saying if you ask me to look at this I
would try and get it so we understand
that the blocks we're working with so
we're looking at your values as being
something if you buy into this as peace
of mind and things that a moral
behaviors that you think I should do the
following you know respect people uh
help people I don't know what your
values would be and now you've asked
something different you've said I've got
this drive uh where does curiosity come
in I put that under one of your drives
and say clearly it's important to you so
let's look at how you're going to get
mental stimulations through those drives
but you're moving on to different areas
again when you're looking at things like
happiness because if you're saying that
it clearly drives overlap so happiness
is something that most people search for
it's an odd Oneness because I know when
I started writing the books I was told
that oh happiness of what people want
and I had a little bit of difficulty
because I don't search for that I'm not
saying I don't want it but it's not a
big feature in me I'm content to be
peaceful you know
um but I'm not someone who searches for
this great happiness and you know I'm
just happy to be just okay every day
that's satisfying to me so I'm a little
bit odd that way
um but if you are saying not Steve I
need this I want stimulation but I also
want like fulfillment because I'm
expecting your Curiosities leading
somewhere
you know so I would be saying to you
let's look at what you're trying to get
that fulfills your chimp brain which is
a really good thing to do that gives you
a great feeling and a wellness and it
may be excitement adrenaline it may be
satisfaction but I have to say what are
the words that are appropriate for what
you're trying to achieve it could be all
of them because then we can start
understanding what is you're doing
but I have to say I have to be careful
because otherwise you get so analytical
you just get on with your life and I'm
saying just be spontaneous but if you're
finding that you're not feel fulfilled
that's when I think let's analyze let's
see what we can look at in the blocks
What's missing
so you're right when you're saying you
I'm not sure you define them clearly and
therefore you won't be using them to
Advantage yeah I think that's accurate I
think that functionally it sounds it
sounds nice and they're definitely
things that I enjoy but when it comes
down to sort of what functional utility
does it give me it can I look back on my
day look in the mirror and go I was
curious today therefore I feel at peace
with myself there are many many more
things including respect for others
which is a really great one from you
that I think would more highly influence
the peace of mind that I have you've
mentioned it a couple of times I want to
dig into this this tension between peace
of mind and happiness and and what's
what's going on there
yeah they sometimes don't go together
you know it's like let's say I have I've
got stuff let's say I've got a member of
stuff who's really not fitting in the
group and we've got me I haven't just in
case any of my stuff are listening
I haven't got anyone but if let's say I
did and I thought you know the team are
not gelling and we've got this person
who's not fitting in with our values or
they're not they're just trying but they
just don't work well then I know that
the right thing to do morally is to
grasp them up and go and see them and
say look it's a mismatch you know
there's no negative in that sense it's
going to be difficult and they may they
may get I've had this in the past they
may attack me and and say all the things
in the world you know you're meant to be
this caring person but I'm thinking it's
for the good so I would leave that I
wouldn't be happy
you know I'm not saying I don't want to
be happy by the way but I wouldn't be
happy but I'd have peace of mind I know
I've done the right thing and in the
long run they may not like me uh and
I've nothing good to say about me but I
know in the long run it's for the best
for them on the team so there's an
example where peace of mind and
happiness don't go together
um and it can go the other way I could
be happy about something uh but not have
peace of mind because I think actually
you didn't do the right thing
you know so overall I'm gonna end up
feeling not so good I'll think yeah it's
a superficial happiness I was gonna say
do you think it seems to me that
happiness without peace of mind is more
difficult to achieve that peace of mind
acts as a a tarnish that can that can
kind of color and Jade any experiences
and that the happiness will inevitably
be more fleeting or more fragile
yeah I haven't done this so just in case
people think oh but obviously it's part
of my job um I've examined all the
doctors and medical students because
that's my world uh um I'm with the Royal
College and you know I want people to
pass I don't like to fill anybody and so
if somebody's bored or anything oh they
don't really really deserve to pass I
haven't done this uh my happiness would
be to pass them
but I wouldn't have peace of mind
because I think you know at the end of
the day you were wrong you shouldn't do
this but I might think
I know there's something so much and
then I'll justify it rationalize
whatever I'm sure they'll learn on the
job and I'm sure they'll be fine and
I've got but that's rationalizing so you
can see there's an example where
somebody might lose peace of mind but
actually feel at the time I'm happy
because I'm past them because if I don't
I'm gonna have such unhappiness so
sometimes we compromise our values which
lead to us having less of a peace of
mind and I'm not saying it's right or
wrong I'm saying it's something people
have to decide on
yeah that's very interesting you brought
up your work with medical staff you've
just done this new study or you've been
you've completed and now published a
study on burnout and well-being I think
amongst nhf nurses and maybe doctors as
well to talk to me about uh sort of
burnout as a concept it's kind of a
buzzword at the moment I think a lot of
people maybe do feel that they are
overwhelmed with workload and stimulus
and I don't really have time for myself
and I feel like the past maybe I was
like more peaceful or things were slower
and then burnout as a concept and then
Let's Fold in this new study and what
you learned from your time working with
the NHS then
yeah I was with NHS for 20 years so uh
it was great time
um
Bernard again it's defined differently
but I think it's Common Sense what we
mean it means you suddenly feel like you
don't have the energy anymore you get up
in the morning you need to dread it so
for a doctor for example let's go back
to my experiences I would do outpatients
twice a week and if I'm starting to
suffer now I was thinking I can't face
it I just want to get through this uh
that's a sign of burnout whereas
normally I'd be getting keen and
enthusiastic to go and see them or or
thinking you know if I get the slightest
headache I'm just gonna for an insect
and you get signs of burnout so there's
a number of them anxiety put asleep but
it's generally this feeling of I just
can't do this I can't do it I'm
overwhelmed as you pointed out so with
that in mind when I did the chip model
which just took off and then uh it's
very humbling because obviously it was
meant to be just for medical students to
learn the new science when liter model
did take off I wanted to go back to my
roots and I worked uh we did a series of
workshops I called it skills for life
and it's emotional management and
understanding yourself so it's based on
a part of the Jungle and we said we'll
take we took 80 GPS from a county nearby
uh and we I said and we'll run eight
workshops and we'll see whether this
affects your health uh your
communication with your staff your
burnout your sickness rates and that was
just a pilot run I did and it worked
fantastically again credit to the GPS
and the staff who were working with the
GPS they worked on it and they said it
did make a massive difference so as a
doctor obviously I'm bringing out this
model which is semi-fun but serious I
want to know it actually works otherwise
it's fraudulent
um so then I took a study with 200
teachers and went into the schools and
was trying to say let's have a look at
you we had three cents to study
and again it's only a pilot run with
teachers in York Birmingham and
Cambridge and and that was just again
just a pilot run so we did it roughly
and ready and the feedback was really
really encouraging so I didn't actually
do the next study because clearly I
can't do my own assessment so it was
taken out of my hands by an independent
research group and I was not allowed to
do the teaching bit I was put to one
side which I accept and I think that's
right and they underwent these series
about workshops and then they did
analysis which is published in the
journal for mental health uh and it
showed a massive reduction in Burnout a
massive reduction in health issues
um and a General Health questionnaire
was used uh to show that The increased
Health was marked so we were excited by
that obviously I'm over the moon uh the
nurses were brilliant in engaging it
brilliant but they took it seriously
because obviously their front line and
the stress on them is immense and and
amazing it was done under covid we had
to do it online because and they all
were brilliant to say we keep going and
the feedback was great so we're now
undergoing another group I'm not
involved independent researchers are
doing 200 doctors
um and again I do a lot of talks to
medical staff because this is my world
and I'm more familiar with the medical
organelle sport
um so it's very encouraging so we run
this for the public as well it's not
just academics or and it's just to say
if it resonates with you then you can do
this and see what you think and the
general feel is it now the research has
published and analyzed that it it does
have an impact I was wary that it wasn't
like something a flashy in the pan
because obviously a lot of therapies and
they see it they don't hold so we did go
back to the GPS months later without
warning and say give us another feed and
found it held which wasn't surprising
because what I'm asking people to do is
approach life differently and once you
do that you more or less keep doing it
but you do have to maintain I do say to
people five or ten minutes a day is all
I ask to maintain these and learn to get
your mind in order before you leave the
house in the morning that's that's what
I'm after what do you think it is
specifically about your approach that is
assisting with the symptoms of burnout
or targeting even the root cause of
burnout and overwhelm
Maya I think genuinely I think it isn't
the model per se I think it's the person
being able to understand themselves and
start looking after themselves and start
understanding things like I mentioned
trigger points uh recognizing anxiety
rather than not seeing it so
um we give teach them about subtle signs
of anxiety Then recognizing how to
detect things like beliefs that are not
helping so we're challenging a lot of
things but it's all about the unique
person empowering them and giving them
the tools to get the life and be the
person that they are that's what it's
about so when you do that which will
include practical things like
communication skills assertiveness but
learning how to communicate with your
human side of the brain rather than the
chimp brain which is emotionally driven
and can often cause more problems so
it's a big overall of looking at you I
think that's why it's working because
the person makes it work they have to
decide I can't decide what works for
them yeah and as you've sort of
emphasized today because we are so
idiosyncratic and because our drives and
our genetic predisposition and our life
experiences and the ways we've dealt
with pastorama and all of that are so
unique
it needs to be something which is
sufficiently scalable and each person
presumably individually finds their own
flavor of this and that resonates with
me because I'm more of an angry chimp
person or my chimp and my human are
Chris High rather than Ronnie O'Sullivan
right and that's why I say I can't I say
this to people only you're gonna
discover all I do is help you and
catalyze where's Claude and suggests but
I'm gonna have to ask you to do the work
it's not me that does the work I I do my
bit but again I'd say at this point you
know it doesn't resonate with everyone
it's not for everyone
um and they're a fantastic therapies out
there my job along with everyone in this
field is to say just try and get the
best out of yourself and quality of life
so you know if people go for mindfulness
CBT these are excellent therapies
they're excellent models to work with I
mean I'm an academic so I like
evidence-based however if people go for
things where there's no evidence as if
it works for you I'm not arguing
right all I'll say is be very careful
that you don't get fooled by something
particularly someone who you know is
giving you stuff that's gonna work in
the short term and then find your
collapse down so it's got to be
something solid there's plenty of stuff
out there to resonate with have you
found a particular cohort of people that
the chimp model Works particularly well
or particularly poorly with
that's a good question and the answer is
no because
it's whether that person gets it I mean
some time ago when I very first started
doing this I was asked to do a brief
television series which was with some
women I got four of them and they asked
me to teach them to ride a bike because
I was with cycling at the time uh but
that to lose weight and learn how to
manage their mind so it was a bit of a
funny a fun series I did I loved it the
women were brilliant they were brilliant
great fun to work with but it was
interesting that the the Chipmunk
bubbles are almost in paused upon them I
mean they knew who I was at the time it
was some years ago well one of them
didn't resonate with it at all and I was
happy I said no I can talk in different
terms but she had a moment where
she'd be she was doing some Sport and
um she'd gone after sport justifying
while she was getting a takeaway
um and she knew she was on telly and she
said I sat outside the takeaway and I
said I deserve this because I've worked
hard I've run off a lot of calories and
then I said to myself you're on a
television program you're meant to be
losing weight and then she rang me and
said I've just found my chin
you said it was bizarre I was talking
and I'm thinking who am I talking to so
sometimes the penny has to drop where
you think I get what the Neuroscience is
but it doesn't happen for everyone and I
that's what I'm saying find something
that resonates with you so who works
with it is the person that resonates so
my younger student is three or has was
three who got it and would talk about
his naughty chimp
um the eldest person that's come to me
that's actually said this really works
is about 80.
um and what he was he was quite annoyed
with me saying why didn't you write this
six years but I was a little boy at the
time I didn't have any knowledge yeah
yeah but I've had a lot of people who
are which is very humbling to me they're
in their 60s and 70s saying ah if only I
had known this so they're the vehement
you must bring this to schools but I
don't want to impose it I think someone
has to resonate so there's a danger of
him pausing and that that's the last
thing I want to do it's got to be
empowerment rounding out that
conversation around sort of burnout and
overwhelm you spend a good bit of time
in the new book talking about robustness
mental robustness and resilience
big buzzwords you know a lot of the guys
that I've had on the show people like
David Goggins who's this Ultra endurance
athlete Joker willink who wrote a book
uh about discipline equaling Freedom
um a lot of discussion about mental
resilience and robustness
um what what is interesting do you think
about or what have you learned about
your conception of resilience and
robustness compared with maybe what what
most people don't understand or get
wrong about it
again your definitions are so vague if
you start looking there are so many
different people saying this is what
robust and says so I had to do the same
I had to say to myself Define it so if
people are following you they say okay
if we use that definition I see what you
get going to so I Define robustness as
having a plan
so we can all become robust it's like
getting a toy for a child and saying
we've designed it for the child
resilience is handing it Auburn see if
it works so resilience is where you go
out of the work into the world and say
right so I would have a mental strategy
and plan to deal with my trigger points
but when I get out there that's being
robust I'm ready to leave the room the
second they get out now its resilience
is the skill to stay robust is to stay
in that same strong position so I think
robustness we can all get to but being
resilient is a skill and I think that's
where people come unstuck because they
start beating themselves up instead of
saying it's a skill that means you've
got to acquire it and maintain it but
also some days you you get it wrong like
any sports person uh for me managing my
mind is a skill and every day I've got
to work on this so every day I do every
day I have usually around four points in
the day where I do a quick check and say
right can we just make sure I'm in human
mode make sure my beliefs are back in
place make sure I understand get
perspective
um that's what I do very briefly it can
take a minute five minutes but that
resets my mind
so I'm resetting so I think resilience
is something you've got to work on and
know how to use your skill but it's not
easy so that's why when I wrote the pass
of the Jungle I was saying I'm going to
show all the basics so you know what how
how things work in your mind what
resonates with you what doesn't so you
can do the exercise to get yourself in a
great place by the end of it you've now
got robustness and you've got some ideas
on how to become resilient and that's
why I did a bit of troubleshooting at
the end to say these are the common
things that I find people say it's not
working for some reason
you know Ronnie O'Sullivan did say as he
also he has permission to sell anything
I've worked them about two years and he
rang me one morning and he was very much
in gym mode and distressed and he said
it's not working it's not working I
quite hard and I said to him have you
done the work and he said no so I said
okay I'm gonna put the form down ring me
when you've done the work so I'll put
the phone now uh and it rang me about
three four days later and I said how are
you doing he said brilliant I said why I
said I did the work
uh you know so the answer is simple
there's no different than anything else
you've got to do the work and the work
is making sure your values are in place
making sure what we did the stone of
life not mentioned with all your beliefs
in place uh and what the rules of the
way the world works you know these are
the truths of life
um and then also put in place a
perspective plan so when he did that he
said yeah it's working again so the
answer is when people say to me it's not
working is I always ask have you done
the work and sometimes people need
guidance because they'll do they really
try hard but they're trying hard on the
wrong things and then you've got to say
hang on can I just adapt that I'll
modify this and so a little subtleness
and then they go ah okay I'm off again
that's why I call my team the mentors
because they're there not to instruct
they're there to Mentor you to saying oh
let me help you there's a glitch here
and challenge things so you can work it
out yeah the uh tendency that we all
have to complain about results we're not
getting from effort That We're Not
Making is yeah very very pervasive and I
see it I see it in myself if I start a
new training program or switch my diet
up or try and do something different
with my bedtime routine
it's like you've done it for three days
one of those days you didn't do it
because such and such a thing happened
or you were away from home so yeah it's
one of the things I'm getting here and
it's interesting there's almost like a a
philosophical underpinning here you know
your own personal philosophy about the
way that the world is and obviously we
we experience the world through the
texture of our own mind it's the only
way that we have to experience the world
even experiences from other people still
get filtered through our own mind
um yeah and yeah it does there is a a
sort of almost like a Whimsical
philosophy uh undercurrent that I'm
sensing through through some of the
stuff that you're talking about making
sense of the world around us
yeah I didn't want to be restricted when
I did this to saying right I mean
obviously I've been taught very well
with philosophical models and medical
models and psychological uh but I did
want to restrict people I think it's
what people want to do with it and make
of it I'm very much uh Keen that they
have empowerment but I still will
challenge things I'll challenge beliefs
people hold because if I think that's
holding them back beliefs about
themselves particularly or all of the
people of the world
um but I will yeah I think there is a
philosophy underpinning it but it's your
philosophy and I think sounding boards
we use friends to do this all the time
we we say something they'll correct us
I'll say oh do you really see it that
way so what I'm doing is doing that with
hopefully the Neuroscience behind it to
give that push but I want to take you
back something said because
um on the thing it doesn't work one of
the commonest things I get and this is
an example of why it doesn't work
sometimes if you do work for a few days
and then you miss a deal to
you can go backwards depending on what
you're trying to achieve so I'm going to
give sleep as an example I ran sleep
clinics a long time ago
and people say to me I just have
terrible sleep and one of the general
rules of sleep is that you it's a it's a
learned behavior
so although there's all these circadian
rhythms they're actually secondary to
learn Behavior so if we get you to learn
a behavior of sleep then your brain will
start to follow this and your body will
the Circadian rhythm is obviously
powerful but it's not as powerful as
habit so I work with people who say
right and I say go to bed whatever time
it is 10 o'clock wake up seven o'clock
and that's your sleep and they'll do
this for say I'm making this up five
days and then Saturday come and say oh
well we're late on we went home at one
o'clock and then got to bed and I slept
in till 10. and the rules I'm being very
black and white the rules are simple for
the next three or four days you finished
you can't do that with a brain so none
of your sleep's gone out until about
Wednesday or Thursday so now you try
again and you say well I'm doing what
you said but that's the subtleties no
you didn't you have to stick to it
Saturday Sunday as well now I know some
people get away with it because we're
variants we're not all the same but the
general rule is once you do that you're
finished it it won't accept this
destruction of sleep
so again I'm trying to point out that
sometimes there's subtleties in the way
the mind works and it's the same with
emotional stuff which is why I
pre-program things about four times a
day because my experience for me is if I
don't then I get minor chimp my son my
team might say major chimp outbursts and
then I think gee and I have to come
around and say okay sorry about that
let's start again
right but if I prime it about three or
four times get it back in tune I tend
never to get one what a really
consistency yeah what I really
appreciate about uh your approach and
what you've gone through today is a real
uh humbleness or sort of a a lack of ego
or at least an apparent lack of ego
around needing to be right and I think
that it's a very strong signal of
trustworthiness that it's just I want
people to be better I want them to have
a better relationship with themselves
people that are around them I want them
to have more peace of mind and live a
more flourishing better life
you have an approach that you believe in
but if there are other things that
people do I think it's it's a very
um refreshing way
in a world in which everybody is trying
to prove themselves to be right and
prove their models and their worldviews
and their books or their courses to be
yeah
no but the the reality is that none of
us are always right and that not
everyone will resonate so I'm not it's
very nice to say it but I don't say it's
humble I think it's been rational that
you know there are plenty of other
models that people have said this is
much better or this I don't get this
chip model uh so I don't think it's
necessarily humble and I think on the
eagle thing to be fair like a lot of
people
um who are in medical
um an Allied sciences and philosophies
and all this and where we're practical
and therapeutic therapists we're there
to help people we get kick hands out so
in a sense you're feeding your ego
because but it's only about for you to
think oh that person really did well so
I thrive and I think it's nice too on
people doing well so to me you know
seeing someone suddenly saying I've
really got my act together or achieved
something like Chris Hoy did you feel
thrilled that you're saying I had a
little bit of a part in that see Steve
you're you're even humble in your
horribleness which is
unfalsifiable I'm Gonna Keep On I'm
gonna keep on accusing you of it no I
really I really do like it and I think
the the idea of the mind having this
hidden metric right the fact that our
Peace of Mind our happiness the fact
that we're living in alignment with our
values we don't see it day to day in the
same way it doesn't appear on a scale in
the same way and I'm fascinated by how
people sacrifice hidden metrics for
observable metrics so uh let's say let's
take um Peace of Mind and money a lot of
the time people will sacrifice Peace of
Mind in order to get money because it is
so difficult to see and I I really think
that one of the things that appears to
be happening here is trying to make that
hidden metric a little bit more
observable by checking in by seeing
where I'm at by reflecting on what I've
done
well again I guess I'm a Doctrine a
scientist at heart and I like to measure
things and so I do like people to see
that progress because we also know our
chimp brains like to achieve as our
humans do so I do push this to say let's
get a skill to measure things even
happiness you know we've already talked
about it
um but I asked people not to give me a
scale of five out of ten because I don't
think that really helps because one
minute they're one one minute they're
nine what I do is I say things like tell
me five things that will make you happy
and they're like simple things so it
could be uh having a cup of coffee uh
going for a walk with the dog or it
could be going out with friends for a
meal so what I do is say right I want
you to measure how many times you do
that in a week
because we know that if you do those
things the chance of you being happy go
up so I measure indirect so I often
don't measure directs I think what's
going to influence you to get what you
want so I'm quite keen on happiness
lists I go on about them because again
because most people do want to be happy
I do want to be happy I've made myself
into this kind of weird person but but
I'm saying peace of mind for me I have a
peace of mind list yes but but I think
happiness lists I think are really
important and I like to divide them into
instantaneous because that can make a
difference to our chimps maybe not our
humans so for me a cup of coffee is
right at the top of the list I'm an
addict so if I if I want to get happy
I'll grab a coffee and think I'm happy
now I even use that as a emotional
blackmail on my chin so if I've got 50
emails and I've got to do them uh and my
gym doesn't want to do emails right but
I know it'll benefit people so I'll say
you don't get in coffee till we do 10. I
have no idea why but it will do 10. so
we both do 10 and then I get coffee
so uh and it works for me so simple
there's an equivalent you may have seen
this in some of the the training
sessions that you've either done
yourself or observed but uh in CrossFit
especially you will have a time-bounded
workout and the coach will be stood at
the front of the room and you'll be your
heart rate's at 180 and you've got the
taste of metal in the back of your
throat and you hate the coach and the
workout and gravity and everything and
the coach does this thing every single
CrossFit gym on the planet does this the
coach will shout from the front of the
room careers get back on the bar three
two one jump on the bar and there's
something about that countdown and it's
like someone's literally put their hand
inside of you and made you do the thing
that they were going to do and the the
idea of like you're not getting a coffee
or you're not going to go for a walk or
you're not going to do the whatever
um there are like these little
bugs or features perhaps in the code
that we have that's running our
operating system and sometimes you can
just inject yourself at the right Point
together you can learn to do it it's the
same and people say to me I work with
the British swimming team
um for a while and uh the the biggest
thing for them was getting out of bed in
the morning because they said it's like
four o'clock starts and it can be hard
and so some of them struggled and again
it's the same principle of saying don't
think just block the chimp because
that's what's stopping you you want to
get off it's only the chimp brand that
says stay in bed or we could have five
minutes more of and and it's irrational
really because you sound need to get up
that's where the alarm's gone so again
it's it's quite powerful to learn to
block thinking and just say no I'm not
going with that I'm acting
um and that's basically what you did
with your Chris get going through so
you're not thinking anymore you're just
acting so what he's done effectively you
know scientifically is turned your
computer on as a behavior it's neither
chip nor human that's got on the bike
it's the computer that was taken over
and said it's irrelevant how I feel it's
irrelevant more emotions there's an
action needs doing and here we go so
he's used to trigger point for the
computer and that's why that will work
but you can learn to do that for
yourself which is what I've done I get
my computer to take over and my children
because okay okay we'll get coffee soon
Steve Peters ladies and gentlemen Steve
I absolutely love your work I love your
demeanor I think that I think it's very
very good and no matter how humble you
are I think that you should uh you
should continue to do the things that
you want to take all of the praise
because it seems very very well deserved
what should people do Beyond uh the
books but those as well if they think
that they want to get even more
information if they want to start
working with somebody on this what is it
that you guys offer
um I mean they can work things out from
the books that's a path to the Jungle is
much more explicit with exercises to try
that hopefully would resonate with
people and it goes through the science
and there's lots of references 400 plus
they can look up uh we run a small
company and we do do workshops for teams
or individuals I do a lot of fun stuff
as well so we have a sports conference
coming up in October I'm going on the
Dracula hunt back to North Yorkshire at
Whitby uh and we're gonna do a fun I'm
going to teach at the beginning of it
set them off uh I think there's a team
bill for my team they loved it so I
thought let's open it to the public so
I'm doing that in October as a weekend
retreat so it's fun but it's team little
fun
um finding Dracula's coffin and then I
do a Christmas conference so we do do
public conferences we have an annual
conference every May where I don't do
all the speaking even please you know my
team get up and do it but we have the
team available to do workshops and they
can join what we call the troop which is
on online it's free I just got on the
chip management website and I do a
one-to-one thing which at the moment I'm
following a pass through the jungle to
try and uh give people something to work
on practically and there's a community
though go on discussion boards so if
people want to join in and they're
resonate they can meet like-minded
people which is what I'm trying to set
up it's working I hope fantastic Steve I
really appreciate you thank you thank
you so much for inviting me if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe